hey guys today it is Wednesday the 16th
of December my name is Jess and you are
watching gains bunnies hey fives next
free update entitled the cartographers
gift is out now and here's what you'll
get with it for the low price of three
343 industries are giving you more maps
for arena and war zone new
assassinations lots of wrecks and the
anticipated godmode forge mode lets you
create your own levels and the feature
has been overhauled to give you more
control and a hell of a lot of objects
to build with cartographers gift is halo
5 second free expansion following battle
of shadow and light in November another
free our state is to you in January and
343 have promised to continue a study
released schedule for new halo 5
contents through to june of next year
ubisoft has detailed the next patch for
rainbow 6 siege which should address
many of the problems reported by the
community the patch includes an ultra HD
texture pack for pc which upgrades many
of the more common textures in the game
including characters and weapons Ubisoft
have said the pack is best appreciated
while playing the game in 4k resolution
the 1.1 update has also made a bunch of
general tweaks and improvements
including fixing hit registration
addressing balancing improving
matchmaking and painless changes you can
check out the full list of changes in
our story on site hideo kojima is back
with a new studio and his first game is
going to be a franchise that will debut
exclusively on playstation a video
posted on the official playstation
youtube account features Sony Computer
Entertainment president and help
confirming a partnership with hideo
kojima house explained that Kazuma will
be working alongside Sony in the
creation of his neck
and the customer said he is thrilled to
embark on creating a new franchise
Kazuma tweeted that his employment
contract with Konami ended on December
15 and added I'm committed to be
involved in creative activities for as
long as I live kajima snus too dear much
like his old one is called Kojima
Productions a QA revealed that the new
game will arrive on PC after its ps4
release and will not be related to metal
gear or the council silent Hills as they
are both tsunami properties on the
subject of Konami Sony added that they
will remain one of FC is most important
publishers and our relationship with
them will not change they will know down
in the comments what you want to see
next from hideo kojima and each other
head to games lots of storage on dying
light succession and a spoiler-free
force awakens review that is everything
I have for you today but be sure to let
me know what mattered to you and I will
catch you same time tomorrow